this is me eating bison ribs smothered
in a spicy blueberry barbecue sauce and
something mouth-wateringly incredible
called a possible and a fry bread taco
what do all these foods have in common
they're Native American cuisine the
cuisine of the indigenous people of this
land made with ingredients you could
once only find here and nowhere else
made by people who are here before
colonists like this guy and children of
immigrants like me hi my name is dart
and if you've seen me before you
probably know that I take great
enjoyment in eating things delicious
lamb fat before it made this video I'd
never eaten a legit Native American meal
made by the Native communities which is
strange because I grew up in the San
Francisco Bay Area but it's pretty
cosmopolitan here
I've eaten Burmese Indian Mexican
Russian Korean Japanese Syrian Peruvian
and Ethiopian food but I've never eaten
at a native restaurant I've never even
seen one there are supposedly some
600,000 restaurants in the US but barely
any of them National Geographic says a
handful or Native American what a lot of
people think of native cuisine they
think of Thanksgiving food or fry bread
which are definitely a thing but when I
went on a road trip through the American
Southwest with my co-producer Thomas I
realize that it's so much more than that
like so so so so so much more than that
so what is native cuisine today what did
it used to be and why don't we see more
of it on every street corner
[Music]
so what's a Native American restaurant
actually like to show you we're gonna
start our story here in Colorado at like
3:00 in the morning with very little
sleep we just drove for eight and a half
hours redness of my eyes so we are going
to Tokyo
which is a Native American restaurant
and that's what we met then we're very
late he's a member of the Osage Nation
in 2008 he and his business partner matt
opened their first restaurant and now we
have two locations and the food truck so
they gave us a behind-the-scenes look at
what their foods like we are in the
kitchen oh my god something is on fire
Wow so we are setting what on fire cedar
we need to burn down a little bit more
into ash okay and then we're gonna mix
it in that blue corn we're gonna make
blue corn mush we'll get some water and
we'll have to move to the stove so this
is the most important part washing it
come to
I'm stirring the water if this is not
that exciting we can do something else
oh this is way more exciting than
watching water boil we cook them in a
bison stock that we make so it really is
the flavor of the animal and we covered
them in this incredible bike seriously
incredible spicy blueberry barbecue
sauce I've never tasted anything like
this in my life
I see it's blueberry barbecue II and
then when you put it on the Vice rib the
richness of the bison rib with the Perry
blends really really well we cut it
right on the grill your knife just goes
right down slides bad all right oh my
god okay
so I grew up in a restaurant I just go
all the way through your interview has
come to an end
then we put it all together beautiful so
this is a hoard Rafi like a northern
plains berry jam you could say
that's beautiful with these colors shall
we dude you're killing me is it good
first with the sauce now with this let's
try the ribs man
the texture of the need that sauce okay
I'm just going to take this I was about
to have a bite all together now but
there was more today we're gonna make
our post a bull okay we're gonna do a
base of the loud rice black beans are
pinto beans you have a preference
shredded bison yes how many if it's a
white puppy corn cranberries cilantro
red onions yellow squash zucchini and
jicama some green chilies I'll do berry
vinaigrette let's show the camera the
idea for took off a came up when Ben and
Matt had this question like why is
native cuisine not present outside of
our community so you know you can get it
at home you get a pow wows and you're
the community gathering but why is it
not available on a daily basis so they
made it available on a daily basis and
today toko Bay is one of the only Native
American restaurant chains in America I
mean I wish we could have shown you how
they make their fry bread taco with
bison or their pozole soup with plump
hominy what are sweet fried nuggets and
it's lady chard soft bread called
Bannock so so good
native cuisine has been around for
thousands of years but the food we had
it took hobby that's something totally
new native food professionals are taking
ancestral ingredients and combining and
preparing them in new ways around the
country you know we're the oldest
cultures on this land but in many ways
we have the youngest cuisine and the
reason for that is it's not clearly
defined outside of like our communities
but how did this new Native American
cuisine come about and what exactly
makes it well Native American for that
I've got to rewind and tell you how we
ended up here
our journey actually started in New
Mexico this Airport is so festive we're
here to cook with a master of Southwest
Native American cuisine who's a chef
slash photographer slash PhD dang we are
on our way to Santa Fe tonight there are
Chili's next to our hotel room we are
here to interview Lois Ellen Frank hey
Lois is part of the Kiowa nation on her
mom's side and Sephardic Jewish on her
dad's side
she owns a catering company specializing
in native cuisine and she runs it with
chef walter whitewater who's from the
navajo nation together they host
expensive dinners showcasing a unique
take on ancient recipes recipes Lois
included in her award-winning cookbook
Native American cuisine is evolved and
it's super diverse there are over 570
federally recognized tribes in the u.s.
each hailing from different regions
tribes in the Great Plains might have
even bison and choked cherries in the
East they consumed wild turkeys Turtles
another small game and those in the
Pacific Northwest had access to multiple
types of salmon and wild onions but
despite that diversity Lois has
categorized thousands of years of Native
American cuisine into four distinct
historical periods the first is the
pre-contact period which is all the
foods that existed before contact with
any other culture group outside a native
people that includes all the food
natives hunted gathered grew and traded
on their own before the European
invasion
and that would be the basis the
foundation for Native American cuisine
so wildgame back and what I call the
magic ate the corn beans squash chili
tomato potato vanilla and cacao
inherently American does that mean that
corn didn't exist outside of the
Americas unfortunate anyone yes
beans squash didn't exist outside of the
Americas the Italians didn't have the
tomato the Irish didn't have the potato
the Russians even in vodka right potato
how the British national dish fish and
chips
did not exist no chillies in any Asian
cuisine in any East Indian cuisine and
the French had no confection using
vanilla so many dishes that are familiar
to you and me chicken tikka masala
spaghetti meatballs Thai green curry
wouldn't exist as you know them without
Native American ingredients which brings
us to the next period so we have the
cuisine that's old diverse sophisticated
delicious and then we have this contact
with the Europeans all right let's just
focus on the Spanish influence and we
can say well they brought horses guns
disease and wrath okay but we don't eat
those they brought domesticated animals
sheep pork beef chicken and the
byproducts of those animals if you think
about Native Americans most of us are
lactose-intolerant
we ate wild game do you think you could
get close enough to an elk to milk it
after a few centuries of this food
exchange native ingredients spread
throughout the world but as that
happened Native Americans were being
robbed of their land millions and
millions of immigrants were coming to
the United States and maybe that's a
good thing for the immigrants but not
such a good thing for Native people
these new settlers really really wanted
land and they pillaged plundered and
killed natives and burned down their
towns to get their hands on it
the US government played a massive role
too they even passed something called
the Indian Removal Act and one of the
biggest atrocities they committed came
to be known as the Trail of Tears
starting in the 1830s tens of thousands
of natives in the southeast were forced
to march thousands of miles in harsh
conditions thousands upon thousands died
those that survived were confined to a
designated Indian territory right around
here and over the next few decades even
more tribes were crammed into the space
my tribe is evicted and moved to Indian
Territory and the land the US government
confined them to little by little even
that was seized by the settlers other
tribes were being forced onto plots of
land called reservations as a way to
control them once there they couldn't
hunt gather or grow traditional foods
like they used to this is when a lot of
native cuisine was lost
whenever you're displaced you lose
traditional knowledge surrounding where
you've been living for thousands of
years what foods grow what animals are
there when to plant when to harvest now
native people were living on unfamiliar
land forced to live without the
resources they used to have so the
government steps in and issues commodity
foods starvation foods army rations to
keep them alive barely we call this the
government issue the government issued
foods for survival these were
ingredients like flour lard coffee and
sugar foods that were completely
different from what natives were used to
with far less nutritional value than
their own traditional cuisine out of
this period fried breads born and so fry
bread is an interesting native food and
imposed government food that we use for
survival those elders if they didn't
come up with this bread maybe they would
have perished but it also represents
colonization that history is why some
Native chefs use fry bread and others
don't and that brings us to the last
period the one we're in now it's what
Lois calls new Native American cuisine
now Native chefs around the United
States are lastly trained equal to their
European counterparts and we are
choosing what ingredients from what
period we want to put into our menus I
can construct menus from any of those
periods all of those periods and the way
we present them are very new so we help
them prep for one of their big events
what are we making today roasted chilies
some stuffing bison inside of it ooh
Anisa starch the kind that holds
together I use quinoa the native people
always tell you like don't cook it when
you're angry you know are you'll make
the food bitter native people a long
time ago devised this method of charring
chilies because when you charge chili
you bring the oil out so the oil is the
medicine and the oil is the flavor I'm
just filling my little little boat with
ya with goodies 1 2 3
what are we making so this is sage from
the garden this is probably the first
ancestral oven we're gonna roll it in
corn husk which I call the Native
American aluminum foil your mummifying
this and we're gonna wrap it in clay
once it's in clay oh it would have been
put into the fire with the clay per
Texas amy was beautiful beautiful
and then the guests arrived and Lois
gave them an important history refresher
it's always about who's telling the
story
so if native people got on boats and
went to Europe Europe would be the new
world and then we ate
[Music]
No how's the food I think Derek has a
good reaction how was it it was amazing
there was so much complexity and depth
to all the flavors everything that was
on this table tonight blew my mind oh
and I almost forgot this is that amazing
and really what we've done is we've
created an ancient oven so you can
actually see the herbs right inside horn
is a pretty amazing plant we can use the
HUS we can use the cops and we can use
the kernel it's very native way of
thinking is zero waste this is a Blackie
of Chile look how beautiful its moist
it's deep
[Music]
I didn't just want to attend an event
ain't the food and move on I wanted to
know more about the people behind that
food and their history so Walter was
kind enough to invite us to the Navajo
Nation where he grew up so we packed our
bags and said goodbye to the hotel after
a long drive we ended up in a place
called Canyon de Chelly
[Music]
fathers are right there the voice
oh that is phenomenally beautiful
[Music]
Canyon de Chelly is a sacred site for
the Navajo especially because of the
towering spider rock legend has it the
rock was home to Spider Woman who taught
the Navajo the art of weaving but the
canyons walls are also etched with a
tragic story of hurt and pain this land
and your connection to it what happened
here 150 years ago people took the long
walk in the 1860s thousands of Navajos
and some Apaches were violently removed
from their lands they were forced to
march to what was essentially a
concentration camp in southeastern New
Mexico I believe they called it the New
Mexico Trail of Tears every teen was
taken away from us hundreds of Navajo
died during the long walk
they were starved and raped and shot if
they can keep up that included pregnant
women and the elderly and the story at
Canyon de Chelly a Navajo stronghold was
particularly horrifying the American
military carried out a scorched earth
campaign they slaughtered the Navajos
sheep burned their crops and starved
them until they surrendered when they
feigned that their crops their animals
being destroyed taking that long walk
without food and water when that
happened when everything is taken away
from you it shatters everyone you know
the Navajo eventually arrived at the
camp but the land wasn't fit for farming
and hunting was difficult there they had
no choice but to abandon their ancestral
foods and survive off of nutritionally
poor US military food rations as a
result over 2,000 of them died of
disease and starvation eventually the US
government released those that survived
but like other tribes they were then
confined to a reservation which is today
become the Navajo Nation these forced
removals of Native people were guided by
a racist ideology known as manifest
destiny that somehow this land belonged
to white settlers and only white
settlers there's some sort of divine
order even to this day some of the old
people talk about what happened and how
we're gonna carry on our traditional
ways that we used to have so much of
native culture was passed down by word
of mouth but being robbed of their land
their way of life being killed and
forced onto reservations that led to the
loss of a lot of cultural traditions
including culinary ones the
repercussions of that brutal colonial
past are apparent as soon as you drive
on to the reservation
not only is there a severe lack of
native restaurants here there's well a
severe lack of everything food-related
the Navajo Nation is a food desert there
are only about ten grocery stores in the
entire area of nearly 28,000 square
miles and 80% of the foods in those
stores have little to no nutritional
value driving around the reservation
it's hard to find much else besides fast
food native peoples traditional diets
have been decimated by years of
colonization and this has led to
extremely high rates of obesity and
diabetes today Native Americans are
twice as likely to get diabetes is
someone who's white and that's why for
Walter helping others from his community
reconnect with their culinary traditions
is so important if you don't pass it
it's not gonna wait they always tell us
hang on to your root hang on to what you
have know that I can always pass it down
to whoever that wants to learn and
you're keeping it alive yourself oh yeah
before we left the Navajo Nation
Walter taught me how to cook this
incredible dish of lamb chops in a chili
honey glaze
[Music]
whoo that's really good and the food was
so tasty
especially this delicious piece of lamb
fat after cleaning up high-fiving Walter
and feeding bones to some stray dogs now
it's there we were on our way to our
final destination the place where this
video started the drive there was very
pretty and exhilarating and if you
remember I was pretty delirious by the
time we arrived so we're back at Okabe
with Ben and Matt where we ate this this
this and this but let's go back to that
initial question that inspired this
whole trip so in a lot of big cities
across the country we have Chinese
restaurants we have Italian restaurants
we have Mexican restaurants but we don't
have a Native American restaurant like
on every street corner why is that
I think for so long the food was very
much held within the community mom's
cooking grandma's cooking dad's cooking
we didn't have a lot of other
restaurants to really look towards to
like design ourselves off of to build
off of and remember that has a lot to do
with the centuries of ruthless
colonization that devastated native food
culture the forced removals the killings
the rupturing of ancestral traditions
that date back thousands of years now
we're at this place where they're Native
chefs I mean like really successful
highly skilled Native chefs and we can
really create what we want the food to
be and we can create it in a restaurant
environment that not only tells the
story of the food but tells the story of
the people and really has like the heart
of it because what we do at the end of
the day is we represent people and that
really needs a part of what the food is
chefs like Louis Ben Walter and others
are bringing about a revival of Native
American cuisine and restoring it to its
rightful place and while the new Native
restaurant scene is still emerging
native food is already in a sense
everywhere it's in your pasta it's in
your curry and it's in your dessert
everyone's cuisine owes something to
Native American
and who knows maybe someday soon we'll
have Native American restaurants run by
native people telling their own stories
on every street corner in every major
city across this country because
seriously you need to try this
incredible spicy blueberry barbecue
sauce on these incredible bison ribs hey
I have a beer anyway you guys native
cuisine is really really good if you
haven't tried it just like I had it try
to find a Native American restaurant
near where you let it drive their
commute there run there try to find a
way to get there because it may very
well blow your mind and hey if you want
more videos like this make sure to click
that red subscribe button below